[Music]
[Applause]
Rich Eisen NFL Network host host of the
Rich Eisen show and Rich gets to
experience all of this you are Mr
combine how are you doing you know
congruence of Interest sounds like that
band that your friend is trying to
invite you to come to the bar I'm
playing hey I got my cover band
congruence of interest can you you know
Thursday night nine o'clock you know you
want to come see it you know like that's
that's what it sounds like I think
that's a Jared Leto's band that's what
it sounds like yeah copper band I don't
know what they cover
um but you know it's it's it's just
because again this is the first time
we're seeing coaches and general
managers since their exit interviews
once their Seasons ended whenever they
ended and so we're we're wanting an
update on things in the NFL media
because we want things updated
immediately and things can't be updated
it's just like of course they want to a
back Shore does two will want to come
back yeah can his head handle it who the
hell knows like nobody knows so
um and that's the same thing with Rogers
Dan like we're all waiting for Rogers
when is Roger's going to give his
decision
and you know
Rogers is being accused of many
different parts of being you know a diva
or dramatic
and you know uh none of this as you
recall Compares at all to the level of
drama that Brett Favre put the Packers
through while he was deciding on his
future yeah I mean there's technically
still time before the new league year
begins two weeks from uh today as a
matter of fact I mean if he was anywhere
in the realm of far of drama
um he would say in two weeks after the
new league year began I'm out and then
two months later or three months later
say I want back in that's far so we want
things now and we want an answer you
know if I said that you could get
answers to any situation
whether it was team or it was player the
one scenario that you if you got that
opportunity would be what or who Lamar
Jackson
oh what in the world happened
last year uh again I called Ravens and
Browns week 15.
um on NFL Network that was a Saturday
game you might have missed Dan because
the Colts uh had the largest blown lead
before it and there was a snow game
between Tua and the Dolphins and the
bills after it you might have you might
have missed that one
um but you know the Ravens absolutely uh
in starting Tyler Huntley in week 15
expected Lamar back before the end of
the season if not the following week and
he never came back and you're hearing he
wants more he wanted he wanted more and
may want more guaranteed money than
DeShaun Watson and and that's that's the
story I want to know what went behind
the scenes why didn't he come back is
there something going on between him and
the team uh contract related then uh as
to why he didn't want to come back
because he didn't have a guaranteed
contract and then of course it does play
into what's going on
with borrow and the and the Bengals and
Herbert and the Chargers and Gino Smith
and the Seahawks and all of these
quarterback contracts that are coming up
who's going to won every dollar
guaranteed who is going to make a stand
and Lamar plays into all of it yeah that
I've had a curiosity about this for
almost two years rich and you know with
no agent and
now there was information leaked to
Stephen A Smith where he doesn't want a
guaranteed contract which I was told
that was completely opposite why
wouldn't you want a guaranteed contract
considering the way he plays and he's
proven more than DeSean Watson is why
wouldn't you say I want what he got or
that's let's start right there if you
don't want a guaranteed contract then
sign the contract it just it feels like
something there it's it's square peg
round hole here yeah my Spidey Sense has
been going off about it again the Ravens
in my estimation based on what I was
hearing and what I was you know going to
say and what I did say with Kurt Warner
on that that Saturday broadcast with the
Browns Ravens is he's expected back and
then he never returned and they started
Tyler Huntley in a playoff game Dan like
what is up with that you know and so
there there there's just something that
doesn't Square and I'd love to know all
about it we're talking to Rich Eisen NFL
Network host they will have coverage of
the combine starting uh later today and
tomorrow now through March 5th uh we had
Tom pellicero on and I said how
important is Bryce Young's
height and he said not as important as
really how much he weighs like
durability more so not his height
um when did when do we find out how tall
and how much price
they should have these guys weigh in
like a fight where they together and
they stare at each other
um they used to do it in public in
underwear until Roger Goodell saw it for
the first time truly and said we're not
doing that anymore
um we're gonna do these weigh-ins behind
the scenes but um long story short is
it's in the next day or two I have that
information somewhere yeah
um but look there's tonight and tomorrow
are the nights where it's really the
most well I I know you heard I heard
your fans think it's not that important
the combine was created to get the kids
measured and absolutely looked at by
doctors doctors that's what this thing
is for yeah and now a lot of it is about
meeting the uh prospects in an interview
room and everyone's going to get blown
away by Bryce Young's
um football intelligence you hear FBI is
a phrase football intelligence they'll
be blown away by his tape and then
there'll be somebody in the room who
might be the old school because they're
just not tall enough just not tall
enough we're not going to go with a guy
that
that that short
um and we're just not strong enough not
big enough and then there will always be
somebody in the back of the room with
strength coach raises their hand and say
I got that don't worry about that so I I
I don't have an answer for who's going
to be scared off and who's not
um Daniel Jeremiah who I'm doing the
broadcast with I had him on my show
yesterday he believes that young is just
not a fit for the Bears or the cold
weather and so folks will know that and
I I think the Bears will eventually make
this first overall pick available to
whoever does fall for Bryce young it
might be our hosts Indianapolis
um but in the meantime they they keep
talking about their due diligence that
they'll have to go through because they
do need to make it seem like they're
going to choose this draft choice uh uh
for their own and and choosing on a
quarterback and and Justin Phil's just
gonna be strong enough to handle that
speculation
one of the topics that I know has
already come up at the combine I'm
curious what you think about this
quarterback sneak rule that the Eagles
took advantage of and were really really
proficient at it yes what would be the
reason why the NFL would eliminate that
um because they just don't want to play
looking like a Rugby scrum they want
they want plays where you can see who's
uh lined up and fans it's easy to see
and it's just not like okay here's what
we're gonna do we're just gonna turn the
game in a rugby rugby and it's just
gonna be a ring of people just shoving
each other around like that's
that's not what the league wants uh but
I do know that some folks believe it
opens up possibilities that you you can
run other plays out of that formation
you know and and that and that there
could be Statue of Liberty plays you
know behind the back handoffs and you
don't know who has it jump passes and
the like
um so to me the competition committee
when they they they uh they meet they
need to do
um three things they need to make
uh roughing the pass or calls that have
been thrown flags that have been thrown
for roughing the passer they need to
send that thing to the sky judge which
they don't refer to it as that they call
it replay assist or video assist that is
used to sometimes spot the ball or know
that somebody's knee was down so forward
progress stops there's enough time to
let the refs huddle let somebody take a
look at it upstairs and review it and
tell the guys or ladies pick it up or
it's good and then make make the call
that's number one number two is we got
to get rid of fumbling the ball through
the end zone giving the ball back to the
defense I hate that rule with a passion
a team gives up 90 yards on defense but
they get the ball back because somebody
fumbles the ball one inch beyond the
pylon as opposed to one inch in front of
the pylon which would cause them to keep
it and the third thing they need to do
is give me a damn seat on the
competition committee already so I can
get in the room on the table Dan yes
okay I am uh I am I am somebody that
should be in that room there is an iron
rich and Eisen so I'm using this
platform for myself well I helped John
Facenda get into the Hall of Fame
now I needed a new testament influence I
woke up today and I said to my wife I
need a new task I need a new Mission a
crusade and now I have it
Get Rich Eisen on the competition
committee yeah they should somebody
should somebody should represent the fan
you always hear that you know let's
change the catch rule if it's 50 people
in a bar they can tell it's a catch then
let's change the patch rule you know 50
people in a bar they can change the top
rule let's change the Tuck Rule let me
represent the 50 people in a bar it may
be a wine bar but bar nonetheless Bar
None
or nonetheless
I would love if we went to the 50 people
in a bar to decide some of these calls
in the NFL
let the refs huddle up let's go to some
bar in Iowa and let's get it done
correct right in the heart line uh have
fun there thank you good to talk to you
as always that's the popular Rich Eisen
NFL Network host and a host of the Rich
Eisen show